to one hey guys welcome back to the
corridor cast now we are officially here
on zoom' you may notice we have some of
the most incredible backgrounds I think
that have ever been presented to a to a
podcast before and quite frankly the
thing that I'm most excited about is the
really bad green screen team you see if
you do this it's you're more like a
silver surfer than you are see it just
disappeared it's clearly tracking as
soon as you eliminate your facial
features you go away unfortunately or
some reason background let's do the meme
oh man alright so who do we got here
today we got Sam Gorski ladies and
gentlemen so back back from the back
from the grave man plans of having a new
baby
we've got Nick Lorant aka tick Lorant
you guys might know him from
world-famous tick tock
yeah I've been just in the middle of the
woods for last week just trying to look
trying to get rid of the we've got Wes
what's going on Wes was good
what's up gentlemen I'm just riding in
from space
nice and of course the burger strums out
of my own apartment yeah I don't get
this virtual background feature
apparently so you got to slip in there
with your spaceship and give them some
background do you need that emergency
green screen man come pick me up dude
alright so today guys I thought it'd be
fun instead of talking about coronavirus
and not really happening I thought it'd
be fun to talk about all the things that
we don't know are gonna happen after
this the unintended consequences I just
read an article by The Associated Press
that the title is booze buying surges in
the US why would lose drinking surge on
the rise as well are they coming back in
here I gotta trim it down here to keep
it up keep it up on the top but I mean
exactly that's it what's going on here
what am I doing wrong it's a great
natural quarantine facial hair son first
of all how do you guys 28 28 I forget 36
beards the cards for you I mean I can't
grow it here the natural redneck thing
going on where it's just right here oh
the girls right there no place else
wow I mean a little but like that it's
it's just like you
sprinkling yes so if you I mean yeah I
[Laughter]
see you guys I think it's really
interesting how like in these times of
crises there's tons of companies that
get bailouts you know you have like
Boeing is gonna try and get a bailout
now because they made a crappy jet plus
then the whole thing tanked on them but
it's funny because you look at movie
theaters and they're all closing they're
kind of in the same situation from a
financial standpoint and that's already
though so supposedly been like coupled
with the fact that people haven't been
going to theaters as often already sorry
I'm curious if that just kind of like
gave a deathblow to certain like like
theater companies because they're gonna
be running now for months without yeah
now are they can they not get part of
the because the Congress just passed a
whole package of benefits yeah they're
multiple different levels and sizes of
companies which is why people are
talking about the Boeing stuff but
regardless of that you know like why
wouldn't a movie theater be able to get
that I guess so but like at a certain
it's a 25% of Gd
P of the country that would you know
need to be reimbursed if I was the
government and I was looking to hand
companies that could be essential to my
economy movie theaters wouldn't really
be high up personally exactly they have
the means now that and they're rolling
it out what's to say people are gonna go
back to that you know as a main way of
consuming movies let's just think about
this for a second because the the the
compensation that's now going to
businesses is looks like it's it's like
two and a half months of your active
payroll yeah if your active payroll is
based upon people going to movies then
you know get that amount of money
because it's based on what previous what
what's happening previously but the real
question is now like is even if once
they get through that is is that gonna
change yeah of course it is sit next to
each other yeah I'll say after that even
after this is all over I I think it's
still gonna stay pretty low or drop cuz
yeah I feel people would be nervous to
be in that kind of situation for a while
what about like six months from now a
year from now you know the number one
movie on Netflix was freakin pandemic
you know I'm saying so like people
started feeding their minds with it and
you know like yeah would you guys miss
theaters would you miss go and go to
theaters or I would yeah yeah especially
if it becomes like it's not even an
option you know cuz I'd say my regular
or before all this happened I probably
would prefer to watch a movie on my
couch in my own you know I kind of just
like it movie theaters are fun and all
but do you prefer to watch a movie on
the couch but once you take the option
away from me I feel you know during that
quarantine after you know no one went
outside yeah I want to go the beach it's
like what okay
yeah so you think that a real unintended
consequence of this is people his movie
theaters are gonna that's this might be
it I think maybe we'll do like I think
if anything they'll do like those big
screenings but like that experience is
gonna be super sketch for a while I was
already buying movies at home yeah like
pretty yeah what was my mo is but I
would wait until they come out and then
I'd pay to either buy them or rent them
and watch them at home yeah I mean why
not it's so convenient if you just sit
him down and make some popcorn there
yeah it's different for everyone but
like for myself and Sarah it's like
every like time we would get a
babysitter and spend free time out of
the house like the literally last year
we always do dinner in a movie like that
was like the number one like and like
for me it's like it's like whole doing
things at home is always by necessity
more than like choice you know having
two kids and we're needed here so yeah
it's definitely not the preference for
sure it it's definitely something like I
think we all missed it's like definitely
a fun event to go to to go out to
theatres it's you know the sights and
the smells of that or like ingrained and
at least our generation but I definitely
think that after this it's gonna
expedite those big theater chains just
going into the ground and then Wes you
you brought up there's that app that
just came out called qui D which is like
supposedly like the future forward like
antidote to all that stuff because it's
basically a subscription-based Content
map but they lock all the content to
your phone like they don't even they're
like you can't even chromecast it to
your TV because it's like meant to be
watched on their phone yeah it's a
multi-billion dollar
like content initiative basically where
everything's like under everything's
under 10 or 15 minutes and it's all like
locked to your phone and it's
subscription-based yeah just really
weird most about this quit form which is
really weird because like theoretically
it's just basically all they're just
doing is it's just really expensive like
web shows yeah like right now it's like
a bunch of celebrities rappers musicians
things like that are putting out the
first set of content and premium content
for people to view and they're yeah I'm
trying to get those celebrities to get a
bunch of people to sign up yeah it feels
kind of like a bunch of try-hards to be
honest it's like it's like we're all
rich and like we don't want to make
youtube videos unless someone's gonna
pay us a million dollars because right
then kwibi raises a billion dollars and
then they pay them all a million dollars
each to make their YouTube videos and
when you're talking about ten minutes
yes it worked for YouTube read though I
mean trying to come for real digital
like professional I don't think but I
don't think that I I mean honestly I'm
saying this with just like just just not
even downloading the app but just
observational II III don't think it's
gonna mess with anything to be honest
because I think they're making like the
wrong kind of content because it's it's
all really traditional like producers
and directors and actors and stuff like
that that are driving the content and so
I think you know like it from my just
the cursory glance of seeing what's on
there it's basically just like really
traditionally made stuff that I wanna
see it's like that cheese because I
heard so people were having shows like I
think
Christian header on my Judge Judy type
show so I've been like that the idea is
unique to them and all they're doing is
shooting it like TV do we want it to be
more organic like I mean like you guys
the quarter videos they're they're like
high-end hey that could be a completely
I mean yeah I guess I guess it's just
like a thing where like at this point
we've seen what that boy we've seen with
that kind of content should be like them
because it's kind of grown organically
online already like that format yeah you
know and obviously a it's grown with the
constraints of the economy of making
online content so like so there's that
whole element who knows what I mean if
YouTube suddenly paid out like a
thousand dollar CPMs like I'm sure we
would be a different type of content
being grown but yeah yeah but but it's
organic still whereas the cui B stuff is
say I can't watch the videos unless
you're subscribed yeah what's the pay I
guess its first 90 days for free but
then there's a payroll yeah yeah yeah a
month I don't know that could either
work really well or bite them in the
butt because people realize how this is
okay contacted us
but I didn't go find it for free on
YouTube I am already paying for Netflix
minutes yeah I think they're going for
the TV show format just kind of longer
form but not to you like I don't like
kind of past the vine and the tick-tock
stuff but it'll work
download it I'm doing it right now like
people are lazy you know lame everyone's
used to you know YouTube and and Twitter
and Instagram people
at hop to go someplace else to check
something out
totally done with kwibi you have like a
big cast of like celebrities and missing
people that really haven't been on the
internet but you've seen him on TV maybe
you know what I mean anyways thank you I
don't know how many shows they shot I
think when do they start they started
they thought they were founded in 2018
so like I don't know they have yeah yeah
thanks for a year and a half so like I
mean they could have played a right have
a little continent and then you know
yeah but I mean I'm just like going
through it right now and it's basically
like okay these there's they rebooted
Punk'd that old MTV prank show and it's
and you watch it and it's basically just
like half of an episode of Punk'd
because it's ten minutes and then I spin
through it a little bit and then now
there's like a traditionally shot like
emotional drama that looks like a
Netflix show so the one query that looks
cool is that the aspect ratio thing yeah
you like it yeah cuz it's like you can
watch the video in full vertical or
sideways and it automatically kind of
fits so I guess they probably told ya
they told everyone all right hey don't
forget okay so here's the cool cool
thing
I'll just show this right now this this
is kind of cool from a technical
perspective the basic filmed it
specifically so that when you go to
vertical it's a frame framed it's still
friend so it's like when you're shooting
for like you know widescreen and versus
TV formatting they've integrated that
automatically so that's kind of cool but
that's the only thing that will achieve
fast-forward on it though in the
vertical I mean I have no idea okay
so so this brings me to a point I feel
like instinctively we have a adverse
reaction to new social and new platforms
I don't know why and this is something
that like ok we did this thicken click
talk video on the crew Channel right yes
and after like giving it a chance in
like actually just like glancing at it
and say oh that's cringe and like you
know getting my freaking panty tik-tok
armband on there's nothing there's
nothing except for people who post
content on there just like YouTube just
like Twitter that is actually cringy
about tick tock in my opinion no I like
and I got we were having fun with it
like I wasn't we originally talked about
it I was super cringed about it it's
true of course of course didn't like
it's not an app that I'm ever gonna bone
but like just writing off anything on
tick tock like people actually do put
effort into them and some of them like a
legit laugh at and that's what I'm
saying like you shouldn't like just
write something up that's in an app like
you should people being that militantly
like cringe phobic is cringing itself I
think your official comment is being
cringe phobic is Nick you are very wise
for I mean maybe it's because maybe it's
because like you have a guttural
reaction
called cringe yourself right you get
like defensive and you're like oh man
but I actually put effort into exactly
okay all right all right enough of that
voice of reason bs because what it
seemed like on its a and I I have them
download maybe I'm wrong and late then I
don't think this is just my aunt I
cringe side coming up here but what it
seems like on its face is a bunch of
studio executives and people at that
level got together and they were like
how do we do TV on a phone and that's
the same problem that YouTube
encountered that's the same problem that
original web series encountered the
problem is you're applying a format that
you're familiar with at a cost within a
certain economic structure to a new
platform that doesn't have any of those
things
yeah and that was always the problem
with people trying to understand it's
it's not like when people invented TV or
when the first movies came out that
somebody was like okay I've got a movie
and somebody was like okay is it ninety
minutes does it have this and that does
it have a three-act structure doesn't
have this and that is it have if it's TV
is it every 11 minutes is there a down
period for an ad break is the entire
episode 22 minutes you know like that
that's all structure that came in
afterwards as like the entire ecosystem
sort of spawned into its own thing and
right now right now we have some digital
ecosystems that work them that work at
that scale but again I think just the
idea of like taking traditional show
formats doing them in 10 minutes and
then putting them on a phone I don't
know if that does it for me I'll try I
think this is pretty I think it's pretty
fire
because it just because it turns like
that like another two years YouTube and
everybody will support our content like
this I think this is a pretty sick
interactive way to look at content okay
thank you maybe being able to check be
able to change the channels with the
swipe up like we can't really do that
anyplace with the with a preview playing
right here okay I'm just switching
channels right now well I guess I think
I think the app developers definitely
deserve some credit because I think it's
ultimately just the fact that yeah
there's a certain style of content on it
yeah they might be inorganic firm here
Wes what you're talking about is
different than if to Sam's point what
you're talking about is different than
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
the content itself you're talking about
the interaction with okay
I think the YouTube developers could
take a few notes from these guys just
for the bars like they're imagine they
take the greatest content creators in
the world and take the continent put it
on this platform okay
Britain plays you're either your here's
your landscape video in 16 by 9 or in
vertical format like and it's just it's
it's mixed in with all this other like
high-end [ __ ] I could see that being
very like dope you know like what
quarter video can we see vertically
right now no that's offline dude
I mean Rick yeah so you think then that
thing like a more convenient way to like
look at still get the same experience
that you can get like this like this I
think you know like how often are we
holding our phone like this all the time
yeah I've been stopping people on
YouTube from doing that exactly I mean
you want that you want to like you know
once the once YouTube and all these
other apps have that technology and they
do that then why should I pay $4.99 a
month to be on kwibi when you know I can
there's plenty of other places and other
subscriptions I'm already signed up yeah
nothing actually it's funny because one
of their shows they actually did this is
something that burns my biscuits a
little bit though one of their shows
called memory hole is like a blatant
ripoff of a like this that's already
been around for like 13 years literally
they just ripped off their logo and
their presentation in the format and
everything and turned it new into a
kwibi show it's not everything is
terrible channel it's literally a
channel that posts like bizarre
everything sane like retro videos that's
just like blow your mind with how weird
they are and they literally stole their
like graphics package and their show
format and they're now putting it on
kwibi which is kind of lame but but the
point is is that you know it's like this
stuff's already out there you know you
don't need to play devil's advocate West
to play devil's advocate I see what
you're saying but think about this do
you remember when YouTube came out with
you could put 360 video do you remember
360 video basically member yeah remember
360 video oh my god 360 video this is
gonna change the way that creators
create well it's because like at the end
of the day it's uncomfortable and it's
not use a lot of work yeah that's who no
one can make it
easier and easier though sure it also
360 it takes the craft out of video and
content making like for the further way
that most people consume any video like
just the concept of anything in general
like start stops because now suddenly
it's like we'll hold on they're not
looking at what I'm trying to show them
then you wreck their eyes you have to be
creative in that way I think it's just a
different approach but alright this is
my my final sneaking okay final
statements I think that YouTube is too
cluttered and this is a great place to
show premium content from for a you know
like your most professional creative
boom and that's okay you cut through all
the bunch of [ __ ] on YouTube that it's
just like a bunch of crap on YouTube
yeah here's here's my final statement
I'm a spoiled little brat who's made so
many YouTube videos over the years so
that I'm never gonna pitch someone ever
again something that's under 10 minutes
and asking for their permission to make
it one thing here is you got to get
Jeffrey Katzenberg to say yeah you can
put this on my platform yeah yeah I
proved up your yeah
there aren't any gatekeepers okay yeah
you you get that you have your freedom
you do it comes at the cost of being a
tiny speck in an ocean of trash yeah but
but yeah that is what you get it does
well hopefully sometimes you got to go
down a YouTube rabbit hole and get your
get your shipwreck
yeah bit content equivalent of like
grinding or farming in the game kwibi
just managed to monetize the trending
page good news with John Krasinski music
videos all TV stars are not youtubers
you really realize how much that
production plays apart I think into the
quality of their content because yeah
like that's the nice little twinkle that
YouTube offers does you still have the
hope oh I can do this - yeah it's like
you can relate to the creators because
we as we all yeah what's interesting is
like YouTube filmmaker or big big league
guys big league guys now have to produce
on our level even it made everyone even
everyone is watching everyone else to do
so that's what I'm feel you you know
that there's a sense of resentment in
all of this content where it's like what
like if you think if you're if you're if
you're from the traditional side and you
come in and you're doing a show for
kwibi
you feel like you're still driving it
Nick
you finally stumbled upon it
we're all just butthurt there's a sense
of that you talk to old guys in the in
the traditional film chewy they're all
butthurt about every them you can test
that working with a bunch of Union guys
just only there's a cycle of butthurt
right in that now you're everyone who's
watching everyone and it doesn't really
matter where yeah that which is which
has never happened before myself like
I'm gonna be getting rid of some of
these social media thank some of these
like streaming platforms cuz there's too
many of them why do I need all of them
you know and what they do they do that
really annoys me is like the license out
a movie to one platform only so you're
like oh [ __ ] I want to watch this
I can't even front watched on Netflix I
gotta go to Amazon not to check see well
yeah it's annoying for me I feel like if
anything they should probably change
like you need HBO because when you when
you were like I want to watch something
really good and I don't want to have to
look around too hard for it you can hop
on HBO and you're sure networks and it's
always good to have in your pocket
because it's not necessarily that
there's like so much it's not
necessarily good and like you know it's
good to have around and kick around
because there's something there and then
if you have kids you need to have Disney
Plus because basically you need to have
like frozen or cars
Milana and three on repeat in your house
yeah basically quick that's that's kind
of how I've been doing it lately and it
seems to work out so threes currently my
magic number those are my three plus I I
like Hulu just for because they upload
day after it airs on TV
[Music]
those are my core four and then
obviously Amazon I already pay for prime
so I get video for free yeah and then
everyone's just got it it doesn't yeah
you already have shipping prime so
everyone's pure trash in there yeah the
only Amazon phone the only call in space
the only thing that's pulled me on
Amazon is the boys that show was pretty
sweet
[Music]
that was fires you know that's two more
gems for you guys I have sling which is
the re able they're casting a basically
for the balls did you see the thing
where he did the move on the goal posts
he did the swing kick to hit the ball
across the field same you know there's
like a whole there's a there's like a
multi-billion dollar industry that goes
around every year called sports a lot of
people watch him what's crazy how much
like great content you can get out of
flinging a ball around changes every
time
every time with her for details this but
you should recognize that like there's a
hundred billion dollars of billions of
dollars every year
that's the joke got passed to a fan it
was crazy we will be looking at that
play for ages I just hope they really
beefed up there tome it's a little bit
that's so how many platforms is that on
app for me that's like a core four and
you have and just are you cutting
Spotify music Spotify do you have
Spotify that's fifth but I don't know I
mean you're listening to music versus
content like I do pay for the streaming
service in the library but you know I'm
not necessarily like consuming content
with my eyes and kind of it could be
playing in the background or whatever so
yeah you did yeah I feel like I'm just
I'm like right why am I like it
sometimes I feel like I'm just
overloading myself with just a bunch of
[ __ ] just to have a bunch of [ __ ] yeah
they're doing a new scene a bank
statement and like it's like $100 just
gone yeah
expense 8 there dude do you think
eventually there's gonna be a loop and
they're just gonna sell packages of all
these streaming service yes yeah like a
talking about like a group to kind of
compact it all together under one
subscription yeah like you got a Comcast
there like that just provides the
logistic need I mean I'm already seeing
that in a little bit of way I my one
subscription pays for Hulu Disney it's
really back in reality is subscription
services are gonna be around they're
here to stay for sure I mean we have one
we haven't introduced it publicly like
widely but and it is you know for our
four core audience so we can put a
little bit money towards a little bit
more money towards things and we're not
expecting everybody and their brother to
sign up we're not trying to get everyone
under the Sun we just want people who
who really want that experience and it's
fine and it's and it's fine you like
that is gonna be reality you're gonna
have six seven eight subscriptions
because there isn't one
person that's just gonna have have run
one-stop shop I mean but maybe in the
future like as an especially as a result
of all the stuff we're currently dealing
with now with the coronavirus like
eventually that'll settle spawn a
trajectory of history where an internet
service provider will come along and do
that and they'll cut deals with all
these companies and say hey if you if
you in say to the consumer hey if you
buy it through us you get you get all of
these for a collective $10 cheaper than
you would otherwise
just waiting for it it's the problem is
the lawyers and the content and they can
never get together around it that's the
thing that's that that's why I can't
believe like the studio systems we're at
such the studios and especially the TV
studios we're at such an advantage like
ten years ago
to come up with a Netflix did it they
never did it because they couldn't ever
they were all too busy like trying to
make a buckin in the near term rather
than thinking about like what it could
possibly be later I mean the closest you
got is who but I mean dude like you look
at what Netflix did to to traditional
movies too and at this point like man
after that after Netflix and now after
this whole coronavirus thing like with
everybody now finding better ways or
more efficient ways to purchase things
and consume things from their devices
like dude and traditional like it's done
like a whole the whole playing field is
now different and I think that the main
thing is the main thing is if you have
something that you're making and it's
consistent and it's good people will
find it which is always kind of been the
case but at the same time it's it's now
way more so than ever I don't think
that's like that I think that's always
gonna be there you know like but I mean
done in the sense of like it's
considered alongside everything else not
and not ikat an upper ash
of everything else it's it's just a part
of the whole 360 yeah it's one corner
one side it's not just what you're
saying they broadcast away like no no
because we're already reselling it
through like YouTube TV and through
slang and all these other resellers and
and I'm gonna get rid of broadcast
there's always gonna be money in
broadcasting there's always gonna be a
way to make money to the type of content
might change a little bit as it already
has with the whole reality TV like
revolution 15 20 years ago and and
that's that started back then but like
now and I don't have anything against
traditional at all I think it's a really
cool medium and it's it's helped get us
here today so there's there's no reason
like we shouldn't look at it and say
that it's somehow like ha because that
whole system allowed everything to
happen in the first place but I think
what I'm saying is it's gonna be a
corner that is gonna be in terms of like
the auspices and the the level the level
of like clout and a level of community
and a level of influence that a program
brings to the world is now cut is now
pretty much equal yeah I don't think any
one TV show can be you know is any
better than any like Netflix series just
because it's on TV only now you know
yeah there's no longer that for sure the
industry at that point you know yeah I
do I think it's good too because it kind
of resets everyone's perspective and
it's like well now instead of thinking
about like where it is now all you're
thinking about is like okay what's the
concept does the distribution model meet
the amount of money that it costs to
create that concept and does it have
room to grow to like a wider audience
and that's it
and beyond those things it doesn't
really matter where it is which is crazy
because for so long like where something
got distributed was the first question
that you'd ask even before you started
creating yeah where are we putting this
where's it coming out
stuff and create stuff and bring it to
certain people and try to get certain
people involved and conceptualize entire
entire sections of lead of the industry
were created with certain distribution
bottles in mind yeah yeah yeah and now
we have so many and now and now yeah now
it's exactly the pope now it's almost
like you can make the thing and now it's
like oh I was going to play it on their
platform like we're choosing it on yeah
yeah like the average quality of
streaming platform shows there's almost
higher than television but right I
wonder how those analytics look between
the platforms you know like where people
spend most of their time and I may not
be sweet to get data but they'll never
show that Stephin ever let you see that
like in promoting where you're at now
that you just you're just trying to gain
a new audience so I think one would
think like let me just get out of all
the platforms so I have something here
that's that's the name of the game yeah
I mean it's many as you like over if you
want if you want to get exposure you
know you're tied to discipline platform
you shouldn't do this like okay well
yeah if I want to compete maybe I have a
little piece of the pie here here here
and there yeah right here yeah
recognizing that like each platform
brings its own type of style and its own
type of content and so like every place
it's just like I can't wait yeah I can
find the action movie over here yeah you
know I was looking for [ __ ] I go to
Netflix
it has everything that's like Fight Club
but it ain't my club I go to Amazon not
there oh no it's on Hulu but no it's not
only it's on HBO delivered to do do got
it
this free trial of HBO for seven days
seven alarm you cancel
this free subscription you did all this
just to watch Fight Club
that's pretty okay yeah but I was
talking about like for example if we if
you were to make some things for kwibi
YouTube and it's like all of those are
gonna be different yeah you know I would
never I don't think I would approach a
concept and say like okay I can
distribute these on all these platforms
well yeah I don't think you're gonna
watch any cord or shorts don't take time
you know I think some of the special
effects all right clip slip in vertical
format just a cool moment you know in
the court situation like check it out a
corner pull like that audience right
there it is so magnetic
like it's I I agree with that but that's
more like marketing than it is like the
show itself yeah what happened to my
screen no I saw you first yourself that
clone in I saw you vine compilations on
YouTube we can remember when people used
to do vine compilations on YouTube yeah
because again vine is the is the first
place where you're distributing that and
then your recutting it to to repurpose
for another platform so I'm not saying
you can't do that with shows but like
there is a home for mo the original yeah
exactly
the originals but like okay yeah like he
says it's the exposure in the marketing
that why you branch out to the other
things but I think yeah you still make
it with that intent of like do you want
to build homes other places yeah I think
we should over time for sure I don't
want to just be attached to YouTube for
forever yeah but at the same time if
they keep updating and improving their
platform and they keep they keep it
healthy and they keep you know a diverse
and like healthy ecosystem between
creators and brands and consumers then
like you know I'm not know so now you're
gonna just be jumping ship for no reason
either yeah
and and I don't I don't think even
jumping ship is the right word it's more
just like diversification and using
different platforms to tell them your
stories which is what my focus would be
it's like Nick like you're talking about
tick-tock there if there are but just
for example like if there were good
stories that we could tell on there and
there was somebody that could do it and
we could monetize it that's the problem
I don't think oh yeah that's the problem
is it's not monetize it's my one is just
gaining audience right I did it I did it
when it was musically and I yeah I
gained I gained five hundred thousand
really quickly on there but how do you
monetize by can you do just put
something I am you you're working you
know like you're looking to get
attention and brands that five hundred
thousand follower view then you might
get somebody that wants to be like hey I
wanna pay to be in front of those five
hundred K but the platform itself isn't
paying you just because you're getting
views and people to follow you that's
not the number that tik-tok has are
crazy so if you can convert a small
amount of those your YouTube site or
your YouTube page of your website like
that doesn't like totally lack value for
us no it wasn't and there is certainly
value in that but I'm just saying like
- better get those cringe gloves on then
there's only so much there's only so
much like intangible spends you can do
you know and be like oh this might make
us money in the form of subscribers on
this other platform which then might
cause us to get views on this platform
that is actually monetized
you know there's only there's only so
much like risk you can you can put into
that sort of thing when you're a Content
when you're the purely a Content company
it's not like we have something like you
know you know in the background we're
making hand-over-fist money on you know
and most creators aren't in that
position even most studios aren't in
that position I mean you got your
Disney's of the world but like most most
contents companies aren't like that like
it's that you're exactly right yeah I
don't have any it's just um what would
be nice to see is is it's some of the
monetization on these other platforms
solidify a little bit yes they they're
monetizing Facebook right now but again
like it's not just the monetization
either it's like the it's the
infrastructure and it's the ecosystem
and it's the share it's like I can't
trust Facebook - well I guess they they
just introduced what what do they call
it it's the same thing as Content ID you
upload a video originally the book and
then you tell Facebook like where the
original source came from on the entire
platform yeah so yeah and I guess they
just implemented that and we should
probably start doing that yeah for sure
you get slices your stuff I've actually
been doing it on every one of our
uploads there's a setting basically it
says posted it says I want to you know
video and audio belongs to us yeah you
can you can pick a certain pages that
are allowed to use your content but
otherwise it's scanning the library for
update
to summarize my point they introduced
this late to us and to most creators
widely late last year
okay that was 2019 yes that's ten years
late you're ten years I've been doing it
yeah like yeah you know and now there's
this whole ecosystem and infrastructure
that's already established from like the
type of things that get made to the way
that the audience is used to consuming
them it doesn't exist on Facebook that
will eventually like grow over time I
mean there's some of that and don't get
me wrong but like Facebook is still more
like viral clip you don't know who made
it you saw it on a page you move on to
our next post
you don't you know if used properly you
can grow you know really strategically
just because they have that share
feature that lives on you know like you
have two pages you got your newsfeed and
you have your fan page or whatever right
yeah and all the fan pages doing or not
the newsfeed is that I'm sorry this week
is doing a static and information all
day all day you refresh that whole
newsfeed pages new [ __ ] up there so all
you should be doing is alright when I
post something it's gonna go to the top
but it's gonna stack with all that mess
I just need to reshare that you know me
and people are just people are
constantly sharing this stuff they're
sharing but it's getting caught in that
wave of information when you are gonna
let some was long gone but when they log
on they see Spanish oh [ __ ]
dang act like that who share that you
know think it's just that quick quick
click action so doesn't that feel
gamified to you though you know it
doesn't it doesn't feel like
gamification like yeah like the
creator's job shouldn't be to sit there
and be like okay how can I scam this
platform so that my videos get views the
day
creators creators job the creators also
like should not be subjected to like
throttle viewership allowing my yeah
you know a brother down to the platform
how do you have this many followers in
and it's like your page doesn't like
wait how well no no right like it's a
it's an answer to it's an answer to that
the algorithm you know and that's the
and that's legitimate it's like you're
working your ass off trying to make
content that people see and you want it
to be seen and you want it to be
original and you wanted to like do all
the things that it's supposed to do like
and you're putting it out there and
specifically on YouTube is the worst at
this and it's just like nothing nothing
happens it's just it's like a small debt
like you know right like you know like
no video we have 3.7 million followers
what the [ __ ] like wait how do you how
do you get reviews out of that like only
a hundred thousand people what is going
on right and or here how did think that
percent it should be way higher at least
seen yeah right no any on the corridor
crew channel like with our midweek
videos are non react videos yeah it's
like million subs and those videos get
to on 300,000 views sometimes there's
like that's it's just kind of like
alright well that's me quick you'd you
to or YouTube plays their own game yeah
and it's called Google preferred and
it's called like top creator and it's
called all these other things that they
these policies that they've implemented
to make it so that it's more curious
right it is fair enough yeah and so I
understand that that's the reaction
you to that it's like well if I can if
it's not gonna work for me
then I'll game if I it manually to make
it work like kwibi you know like if they
something like that can survive then
that bed that becomes the old gatekeeper
model where now all there's something
there's like an executive that needs to
approve your show to put it on there and
they're not letting everybody mm-hmm
and we'll see you know that works that's
partly why I have concerns about me but
I'm gonna download it I want to see some
of the content you know if it's any good
some gems you know it's meant for the
average you know yeah you paying that
five five dollars a month for that
elevated toilet time you want to pay for
your poops we all switch backgrounds
guys swipe up different areas it is a
catch-22 West no matter what you do yeah
especially when you're especially when
you're like whether you're trying to go
from one platform to another or whether
you're starting out or whether you're
trying to do a new show anything that's
not already established is a catch-22
and that that's the that's the that's
the whole game you
as a creator and that's the game that's
always been played ever since like the
beginning of Hollywood yep is it your
doing they never say you want to do
better than what your parents did it
this is just kind of like I feel like we
don't want to gather over there with all
right so what I think about it is you
know this is just the industry event and
suck again and what we don't want to do
is you want to be on that wave that's
how we stay current or something young
you know be on the way from what's new
you know we don't have to [ __ ] like
them in where and I think like that's
their that's employing the philosophy
that you should be employing not just
like with content like with your whole
approach to life and that is like
there's this idea that you listen to
people because you might actually have
something to they might actually know
something that you don't know exactly
and and what what however old they are
ever however young they are and I'm not
necessarily saying like you should be on
it's like oh hey the kids are doing tick
tock so let's get on tick tock and
that'll be like the thing you know cuz
that's forced that's tried that's a name
that's not that doesn't that's not
original are not [ __ ] looking at your
tick tocks know they don't care how many
you know maybe the remover shares don't
really care about the shoots like yo I
want to push it you know and make money
can do you yeah exactly and if you find
something on tick tock that is from
somebody and it's funny and it's
creative and you can tell they've put a
lot of work into it and and it shows
from not only like the their profile but
from like the you like novelty of what
they've created and everything then you
know that there's talent and you know
that there's something there
and that's all that really matters a bit
yeah yeah you want to elevate their
craft you know at that point you know I
can you [ __ ] do an arm dances only
gets it's not like I think I think it's
just a big distraction you're not gonna
make it I don't think there's a
professional career seriously
knowing our dances the biggest person on
there as like I think 45 million
followers like 17 or 18 year old girl
and I think she's leveraging that offend
them to to do other things but the fact
still remains like if you go to her page
she's doing arm dances right and there's
there's gotta be somebody probably
probably many dozens of people on there
that are doing something that's way more
creative and funny that just it is it is
more than that there's like funny things
but like it's a lot of recycled content
it's like a lot of like voiceover liking
film a scene from a movie and you just
reavoice it yourself and then make a
scene themself so it's like that I can
do it too tight you can't you can't let
the most popular stuff on a platform to
find the platform either there is if you
did that with YouTube or you did that
with yeah it's a bad one because the
most popular thing is gonna be the
lowest hanging fruit and that doesn't
look kindly upon humanity's intelligence
at all know like those go in and out
well you don't say you have to have
substance behind it like okay yeah you
could do a trend but can you make some
like original content you know I think
that's what's your what's your 20
percent contribution to the trend yeah
yeah yeah I read something the other day
that's kind of stuck with me said every
time I lost money is because I believed
what I didn't know wasn't important so
oh nice that's a good quote all right
you know I tried it like at least be
aware you know with yeah I know yes it's
great to know what's going on in the
marketplace you know but you know kind
of what Jake was mentioning is stuff is
you gotta you gotta know what works for
you and what's you know what's the type
of content and an image you're putting
out there and what's the platform that
works for the stuff you're trying to do
you know if you are trying to be that
that influenced your Instagram model
type in man maybe tic TOCs totally your
Avenue but you know filmmakers and stuff
you know a little bit you know we're
focusing on that narrative in the
platforms then but yeah I think it's
just like judge the content on the
content not clicking no a lot more where
it's at Wes and you know me you and Sam
being in our mid-30s here I mean have
you have you because I've experienced
this like you find yourself it's very
easy to find yourself get into that
salty side of I will do that like the
past like two three months my my girl I
was like yeah I'm like you gonna do
tick-tock I'm not doing this you know
like I don't like that you don't think I
don't want to do it you know like that's
not for me even though I have like all
these farmers and then I it's like you
know really sit down and think more so
like whoa all right I might even like
feeling like that just swing that come
from where is that like this they
encompass nothing I don't know maybe
because I can't dance at this point in
the industry at this point of my career
like you know what it what is what is
to find that right there is not I'm a
creator left direct I want to make high
any constant that's where my mind is
that that's that's what it is
you know when I work with the best
visual effects I want to work with the
best cinematographers and I want to make
dope [ __ ] with like friends like that is
what I truly want to do and I want to
make movies
boom me saying that tick tock is just
kind of stupid cuz I'm just you know it
takes my time it does it takes zero
percent of time like you can get really
technical with it but like I want to be
creative on it I could I did I did a
video of my dog hanging in a bag just
like kind of like it's ironic comedy you
know there's like some people like
messing with their Paris Twitter so that
couldn't live very well on YouTube like
I feel like known to be like a 15 second
clip of me messing with my dad with a
couple of years old but like for
tick-tock it's like why not have that
car it's funny point is that it's not
it's there's it's also not wrong to say
like hey this is this is the type of
stuff that I want to make storm doesn't
suit me yeah yeah but it's it's not
wrong to say that but it's it is wrong
to say like this platform doesn't suit
me because it's got because all of this
is stupid girls dancing with arms yeah
you are what you are saying you don't
point you are just the groupthink
mentality who just goes and does the
yoga pants' videos of opinions you know
like you're just in the other way yeah
yeah cuz that's true creators if you
wanted to you put the effort in and you
make creative stuff for whatever the
platform what we're trying to say is get
out there
and wanted your own content farm you
wanted to be a creator anywhere on any
platform we have the original emergency
green-screen blanket available oh it's
full look at that it's foldable it goes
with you anyone you want it'll keep you
warm I mean really Wow there's nothing
better to get right now guys if you
wanted to start your career as a
filmmaker then a green screen see like
strange luminescent monitor lighting
that you have going on on your face
[Laughter]
there okay okay well this was a fun
podcast guys yeah
the parks yeah I'm glad we talked about
we talked about and I appreciate a
little no I mean if you want to create
just go create whatever platform it's on
you know go do it yeah go do it that's
been our motto from the beginning if you
want to do it just go do it so whether
it's tick tock kwibi or YouTube created
alright this is how we're gonna sign out
guys